regardez ce sourire qui pétillent à 72
ont tous déjà renner pour les janvier il
aurait pu se contenter de contempler les
sur papier glacé eh bien non les joueurs
seulement les jeannois
béjart freddie mercury mozart
même jeunesse
quinn et mozart ça choque certains
s'affairaient sourire beaucoup d'autres
pourraient me sens tellement unis est
tellement proche que ça me semble
logique
le presbytère n'a rien perdu de son
charme la phrase claque comme un réveil
en sursaut
c'est le patchwork père maurice déjà à
la mémoire de son ancien jardin de paix
ni mercure
issu du sida
la vie continue la vie doit continuer il
faut penser à ce qui sort vivant il faut
penser à l'avenir
je pensais à la jeunesse ce soir elton
john dira pour nous merci et maurice
béjart l'art est plus fort que la mort
message reçu
et